my goal when I go in the studio with the  singer is I believe in my head that I'm  gonna get a better vocal out of this  singer than he or she has ever done  before or ever will do again I got a tip  that this young singer was up in Canada  she was already famous in Quebec so I'm  not taking any credit for discovering  her I flew to Montreal  I drove a hundred miles in the rain and  was performing in a tent the weather was  awful but I could not believe that David  Foster was going to come and hear me  sing that night I'm about to meet one of  the greatest producer of all time  tonight he came and he watched a show  and then we met after when I heard her  sing it was like that when you watch a  movie and everything just goes  [Music]  was her and her singing and it was just  this phenomenal that went my god  millions and millions of people are  gonna love this woman  [Music]